so somebody went on my youtube pretended
to be me
was giving a whatsapp number saying
what's that me for investment advice
so i'm going to call them up and see
what investment advice they can offer
i know it's a scam because they're
pretending to be
hello good me hi hello hello
good morning good morning
good morning how are you i just wanted
to speak to someone
could you say um you work with samwell
yeah i'm the manager of cryptocurrency
summit um is it can i speak to someone
is he there
no so do you wish
uh yeah i'm looking um i'm just looking
to make some money
you know okay okay
so what do you think
as an investor all you have to do
is once you purchase bitcoin
you um your bitcoin into your trading
slot address
that will be created for you once that
is done once that is done
you'll be given a link
so assess and monitor your trade so your
three duration
is done do you want to start now with
the standard of capital of how much
please
um maybe maybe 100 pounds
[Music]
okay it does sound a tad bit suspicious
how long have you been working with
samuel
i've been working with someone for years
now
and it's hard for me to believe
how do you mean it's hard for me to
believe you're working with samuel leeds
why because i've never heard of you
judge harry harry no
when when you get in the website you can
go through it and
also contact customer care um
i think i would know if you're working
with samuel leeds because i am samuel
leeds
i think i would know if you're working
with samuel because i am sunny or leeds
ah not good
i get very tired i get very tired of my
youtube being spammed by scammers like
you
go on so
he would have taken my money wouldn't
accept 100 pounds wanted 500 pounds
if anyone's asking you for money and
you don't know who they are he said to
me 100 pounds too little
i only accept 500 pounds that's not how
business people operate
what business people do is they'll say
in fact 100 pounds is too much
just do a pound and see that it works
and then do
10 pound and then do 100 pound and build
up trust and i have people coming to me
all the time saying to me can we do a
joint venture can i put a million pounds
into a deal i'm like well hold on
start small start with something small
and build up other people saying samuel
can you mentor me can you be my trainer
hold on pay me a pound and come to the
crash course for two days
and see how it is watch some youtube
videos for free and see how it is
that's how business people operate just
be careful don't be careful people say
don't go to the crash course be careful
it could be a scam it's like no
don't be careful building up
relationships with people
you know trying things out being
open-minded being open-minded is good
but if you're investing in
cryptocurrencies or anything or property
or you in training
start with free stuff start small start
with small trades start with small
investments and slowly build up to
bigger and bigger deals
and bigger bigger investments you know
that's my advice so be careful out there
you know it's a crazy world um this dude
never heard of him i never will hear of
him
because you never you you'll never make
um
proper money unless first you build
relationships and give real value so
mr scammer in the comments you should be
ashamed of yourself
stop what you're doing is wrong and if
you see somebody doing that
report it delete it and ignore it anyway